in this lesson we're going to talk about
how to solve equations involving
fractions and more specifically how to
clear the denominators to make them a
lot easier to solve we're going to go
through two examples so let's dive in
this first example now we look at the
fractions and we say h what's the lowest
common denominator or you could say
what's the least common multiple or the
way I like to think about it is what's
the smallest number that 15 divides into
three would also divide into that number
and five would also divide into that
number
and that number here is going to be 15
so what we're going to do to clear our
denominators is we're going to multiply
the left side of the equation by 15 the
right side of the equation by 15 that
keeps it balanced or you can think about
just multiplying every term by the
number 15 now when you multiply by 15
you can think of this as 15 over 1 and
so right next to each one of these terms
I'm going to write 15 over 1 15 over 1
15 over 1 now what you can do is a
little bit of cross reducing like see
the 15 and the five five goes in here
once five goes in here three times 3 * 2
is 6 1 * 1 is 1 6 / 1 is 6 and see how
we cleared that denominator we just have
an integer now uh we don't have that
fraction same thing over here the three
and the 15 we can cross reduce three
goes in here once three goes in here
five times multiply the numerators that
gives you five multiply the denominators
that gives you one 5 ID 1 is
5 and then over here you can see the 15s
cancel numerator and denominator we're
left with 4 over 1 which is just equal
to four so you can see this is a lot
simpler equation to work with because we
just have integers and not any fractions
so I think you know what to do from here
now you just want to get the variables
on one side numbers on the other so
we'll add five to both
sides that gives us 6X = 9 we want to
solve for one of the variables so
instead of multiplying by six let's
divide both sides by six keep it
balanced
and then now you can see that uh 96 we
could divide the top and bottom by three
that would come out to 3 over two which
is 1 and 12 and you solve the equation
let's look at number two now now number
two is a little bit more challenging
because we've got some parentheses here
but look at the fractions here we have a
denominator of nine three and you can
even think of this as a fraction uh by
writing it over one because anything
divided by one is itself so we want to
ask ourselves what's the smallest number
that nine goes into three goes into and
one goes into with uh evenly without a
remainder well the smallest number would
be nine okay or you can think about this
as the lowest common denominator or the
least common multiple so what we're
going to do is we're going to multiply
the left side by nine and the right side
by nine or you can think about
multiplying all the terms by nine and
that's going to keep the equation
balanced when I multiply by 9 that's 9
over
one uh 9 over one 9 over one okay now
you might be seeing over here Mario
what's going on with this well this is
all one group okay so if I multiply by 9
over one that's multiplying this whole
group by 9 over one I don't have to do
it to the two or the Y I'm just doing it
to that coefficient in front so now look
what happens the nines cancel numerator
denominator we're left with 5 over one
which is
five over here the three and the nine we
can cross reduce three goes in here once
three goes in here three times so 3 * 1
is 3 over 1 which is
3 and over here we have 2 * 9 is 18 ID 1
is itself just 18 so you can see a lot
simpler equation to work with all we
have to do now is solve and I think you
know what to do from here we're just
going to simplify the left side and the
right
side if you have questions about solving
equations check out some of my videos
about uh one step two step and multistep
equations now what we're going to do is
we're going to get the variables on one
side and the numbers on the other so
let's go ahead and subtract 3 y from
both sides that keeps the equation
balanced right and then what we're going
to do is we're going to add 10 to both
sides that keeps the equation balanced
and so you can see we have 2 Y is equal
to uh
28 okay 18 + 10 is 28 and then instead
of multiply by two let's do the opposite
we're going to divide by two to get y by
itself whatever we do to the left we
have to do to the right and 28 divid 2
is 14 and you solve the equation so
great job if you want to see more
examples like this working with
fractions clearing the denominators
follow me over to that video that I did
right there and we'll get some more
practice I'll see you over in that video